ربما لا يمكنني ان ادعوكم لزياره فلسطين
لكن ساصبحكم اليوم لقطعه من فلسطين في
بلده وود بريتش في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه فكره رجل اعمال الفلسطيني
فيصل صالح عندما اسس متحف فلسطين الولايات
المتحده عام 2018 بهدف البحث والحفاظ على
التاريخ الفلسطيني وتقديم الفن والقصص
الفرديه في الداخل والخارج فكره فيصل صالح
لتمحور ايضا حول مواجهه الصوره النبطيه
التي تعكسها وسائل الاعلام معاديه للقضيه
الفلسطينيه واظهارها بشكل انساني على ايدي
الفنانين والشعراء وبعده هذه السنين اصبح
المتحف نظارا لمسؤولين كبار بل خرج من
الولايات المتحده ليالف العالم بفنه واخر
جولاته في معرض لنادي البندقيه
[موسيقى]
نورنا مدير متحف الفلسطيني في الولايات
المتحده فيصل صلاح سيد فيصل اهلا بك شكرا
على تواجدك معانا نورتنا في الاستديو متحف
فلسطين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حدثنا عن محتوياته وعن اهداف
فلسطين في الولايات المتحده
عددا كبيرا من اللوحات الفنيه ويمثل حوالي
اكثر من 60
فنانه وفنانه فلسطينيين في اي وقت كما
يحتوي على صور تاريخيه اكثر من 100 صوره
تعود الى عام ما قبل عام 1948 وهناك
العديد من التماثيل والملحوتات
والاثواب الفلسطينيه همم المطرزه القديمه
الى عدد كبير من همم الكتب والاشياء همم
تراثيه الاخرى
احنا عم نشوف هذه الصور معك همم جهودكم
تخطط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اقمتم
مؤسسه اقامت معرض في مدينه البندقيه
الايطاليه زاروا 100,000 شخص حدثنا اكثر
كنا نبحث همم
طريقه
لنشر الفن الفلسطيني في العالم
ولم نجد همم احسن طريقه من المشاركه في
بناء البندقيه لانه اهم همم تظاهر فنيه
همم في العالم البناء هو اطول عرض همم
يستغرق سبعه شهور همم
يعتبر همم
الاهم همم معرض فني في العالم
فقدمنا طلبات واشتغلنا في مده شهور همم
وفي النهايه همم
اخطاء البناء لتقبل طلبنا ابو اختنا لنقدم
ما يسمى
الافانت من ضمن 30 مؤسسه فنيه من انحاء
العالم
الزوار 100 الف زائر
[موسيقى]
نتحدثنا من من شعوب العالم من الناس اللي
ظهر والمتحف يعني هذه الفتيات همم
[موسيقى]
الزوار عمالقه
وعندك هدول عينه عينه هان اه فكتبوا اشياء
يعني
لما انا ابدا اقراها عيني بدمعه يعني ما
بقدر اقرا كل الكتاب يعني بحط يعني
بتاثر يعني معطفيا في نشوف
الناس هذه مثلا حنظله واحد رسم حنظله
يعني الزوار اتو من كل اصقع العالم
هناك همم
معظم الدول في العالم ممثله في هذه هذه
الكتب وكلهم يتمنون
الفلسطينيات وفي ناس همم حطوا اساميهم في
مثلا همم في همم
اه
امراه من من قريه اسمها طنطوره في في
فلسطين كتبت اشياء جميله وفي الاخر كتبت
انها عمرها ما شافت فلسطين يعني شيء شيء
بحزن يعني
القرى الفلسطينيه المدمره وطرازها
المعماري واقمت مسابقه للمعماريين لتسيد
هذه الكره افتراضيه
على البناء اقترحوا لنا ان نقدم طلب
للمشاركه في البناء للمعماري والذي سيكون
في العام القادم 2023
وسيكون لمده ست شهور ايضا همم
اقترحوا لنا يعني لانهم يعرفون ااه
قضيه فلسطين واهميه همم الاشياء التي
تتعلق بهذا بهذا البناء البناءلي
فبا بالتعاون مع مؤسسه الارض الفلسطينيه
برعايه الدكتور سلمان ابو السته همم سنقوم
بتقديم عرض همم يركز على الدول على الكره
المهجره والمدمره في عام 1948 قامت القوات
الصهيونيه همم اثر انشاء دوله اسرائيل
بتدمير وتهجير اكثر من 500 قريه فلسطينيه
معظم هذه الكره لا تتزاعل كما كانت في عام
1848 يعني انقاذ واطوال
فهناك مسابقه تقوم بها هيئه الارض
الفلسطينيه حيث يشارك
الطلاب الهندسه المعماريه الفلسطينيه بهذه
المسابقه ويختارون قريه ويعيد تصميم هذه
القريه بصوره الحديثه ويتخيل كيف تكون هذه
القريه اذا حررت فلسطين وكانت حره
فاخترنا اربعه من هذه الكره او اربع طواقم
من الطلاب وسادداتهم
يمثلون اربع جامعات جامعات بيرزيت في
الضفه في جامعه غزه الاسلاميه جامعه
البلقاء في الاردن وجامعه الاردنيه
الالمانيه
فهذا يمثل عدد كبير من المشاركين همم
سيد يتضمن العرض همم بعض الصور التي تظهر
الانقاذ وتظهر
الاطلال التي بقيت جزء من باب قبل من
الدار احيط اشياء يعني اشياء همم عاطفيه
جدا لما الواحد يشوفها همم
وسيكون هناك عددا من اللوحات الفنيه فبعض
الفنانين الفلسطينيين سيشاركون برسم بعض
هذه الكره وبعض هذه
شكرا جزيلا شكرا مدير متحف الفلسطيني فيصل
صلاح شكرا لك
ان شاء الله
مع المعرض ههه شكرا